damar Smith joining us on loan from the
NFL Players Association and good morning
des Morris how are you good morning Dan
how are you big shout out to the the day
Nets hope everything's good with you
yeah but I was curious that is this a
victory lap you're taking right now no
I'm in my backyard playing with the dog
so I fly to Miami with our player reps
this weekend the vote is in the hands of
the players we believe in a democracy so
other than the victory lap with me
chasing the ball that's the only victory
lap I'm done right now could you've
gotten this deal done without a 17th
game it was clear from the owners not an
early deal so I just assume you mean the
deal that's on the table now yeah they
conditioned the early deal on a 17th
game after they rejected the players
opening proposal to do a early deal
based on a 16-game schedule give me the
details though from the player's
perspective on a 17th game what are the
biggest concerns here besides the
obvious one with just an extra game that
you can get hurt
right I think that's primarily it I mean
we certainly don't haven't talked to
many players who would prefer to play a
17th game I think if players had their
druthers there's some who would want a
14 game schedule but there's also
players that I've talked to who said
that a 17th game schedule would be okay
if there were XY & z built around it and
that XY and Z for a union revolves
around better wages better hours better
working conditions and better benefits
and that's what this deal has in it and
I certainly understand and and you know
nobody understands better than me after
going through a lockout in 2011 where
the owners wanted to have the
unconditional right to move to 18 or
even 21 games I certainly understand
that fight and we we capped that
in in 2011 and that was one of the if
you remember one of the major issues in
the 2011 lockout but coming up with an
early deal package that contained many
of if not virtually all of the top
issues that our players identified both
during the rep meetings and during the
time when I was out with the teams
that's what's on the table but you know
this is a democracy and and I understand
that democracies can be messy we can we
can turn on and look at the primaries
right now and know that that's that's
true the men make a decision where
everybody is heard and everybody gets an
opportunity to vote and that's all I can
ask for what happens though when you
read JJ Watt Aaron Rodgers Richard
Sherman Russell Wilson making public
comments about this your role after you
read or hear those comments is what my
role doesn't change I'm a union leader
and you know if I look at but you don't
reach out to them individually just to
say hey you know share this with me you
know let's tighten this don't put this
out here unless everybody knows exactly
what's involved in all of this yeah you
and I have known each other long enough
you know and you know I never really
talked about my conversations my private
conversations with players I see their
their public mentions but I also I guess
where I was going with being a union
leader is we're in a world where people
have platforms to express their opinions
and I would much rather have a world
where guys feel free and and certainly
nobody feels any constraint nature to
voice their opinion I'd rather have that
then people who feel like that they're
afraid to a voice their opinion or fear
that there's some sort of retaliation
you know one thing we can Bert we can
both agree on we certainly don't have
that so I would much rather live in a
world where our guys believe that they
have a voice that this is run like a
democracy and as a union leader you
simply take what people want to say
publicly as part of the process when is
this 17 game schedule going to be
implemented that depends a lot on when
the owners would want to do it you know
they are looking at the opportunity to
literally tear up the current TV deals
which for the most of them don't expire
until 2022 they want to negotiate new
television deals preferably with with
labor peace because those TV deals will
be substantially larger if there's labor
peace
normally the earliest that we would have
a 17-game schedule probably 21 at the
earliest okay but a lot of that depends
I think on the television deals of which
the players get 55% why was it so
important - it felt like this was being
expedited and I got a little nervous as
I was looking at this that if the owners
wanted and wanted expedited then I
worried how good a deal it was yeah I
think that is probably one of the most
unfortunate and and and and incorrect
narratives that's out there we started
meeting with our players in 2019
actually going back to 2017 telling them
to get ready for a work stoppage in 2019
we had three days with the largest
player rep meeting that we've ever had
listing all of the issues that were
important to players in April May of
2019 those players actually put together
a proposal and gave it to the owners so
that was almost a year ago so this
process actually started nearly a year
ago where we took the ideas and then
certainly the theme that came out of the
meeting last year was we had to do
something to take care of the the core
players the majority of our players to
make sure that they had better wages uh
more control over their working
conditions and certainly better better
benefits but that process started a year
ago I know that but you know sometimes
the public doesn't really focus on
things until they bubble up in the media
but to say that this was somehow rushed
or expedited
is not only not you know not not the
right narrative it's just utterly
inconsistent with the facts I think the
other thing that perhaps people don't
understand is a lot of these
negotiations also centered around many
of the positives from a new collective
bargaining agreement actually going into
effect a year early so our deal doesn't
expire until March of 2021 virtually all
of the benefits of this new collective
bargaining agreement including the 20
percent raise for the core players goes
into effect a year earlier than we would
if if we waited until expiration these
d'amours spent the executive director of
the NFL Players Association a couple
things that came to mind when I saw this
like why 10 years and I don't believe
there's an opt-out and it feels like
it's the Habs against the have-nots here
in your unit well let me do the second
one first
you know I truly believe in this union I
do and when I took this job over in 2009
I made a commitment to make sure that
our players were more involved and and
they have been that players were going
to be forced to make decisions and and
they have been and that we were going to
be a union that included representation
by by former players and and thankfully
we have a system now that is far more
inclusive of all of the rank-and-file
including former players so you know -
your your point of the haves versus the
have-nots and the perception of that I
can't really do anything about the
perception all I know is that Aaron
Rodgers is a is a rep Kirk Cousins as a
is a is a rep when we went to the
lockout Tom Brady was a rap drew brees
was on the executive committee on the
other hand you've got guys like Nick
Sundberg
and Zach deeossie who are not star
players but they're also reps and on the
EC so I can't really do anything about
the perception I know that our
leadership is made up of a cross-section
of players and I'm thrilled about that
with you know to your to your first
question you know this is this is still
a democracy and and and I'm never gonna
really apologize for that do you think
you could take Roger Goodell are you
talking about a armwrestling race how
about armwrestling oh yeah okay what if
you went into the Octagon well I'm a
little bit of a germ guy so the fact
that there's already blood on the floor
which making a little squeamish but
other than that I'm still pretty
confident yeah how about we set that up
I love the fact that I can expect a
completely off the wall well you know
this show and you're in pretty good
shape I you know I figured you know
Goodell sees rangy he's rangy he's got
he's got he's got a little bit of height
on me and and look I think it would be a
pretty good fight do I think I'm
probably the first person who would
cheat yes that's that's it's not part of
the game
yeah so if we had to go into an octagon
and there was a WWE folding chair nearby
you know that's what you have to use
have you ever been mad enough that you
wanted to punch him like in your mind
[Music]
yeah the closest I get to physical
activity now is watching my son play for
for Maryland lacrosse that's about
that's about as good a shape as I'm in I
can make it into the stands and I can
make it out of the stands that's about
it
well good luck with this yeah you sound
pretty good for you know we got it got a
little bit of there is there a Cliff
Notes version of this though divorced
like 456 pages combined
there is a Cliff Notes version that we
sent out to all of the players and all
of the agents you know what I know a guy
who knows a guy I'll make sure I said
money that's great thanks enjoy your
weekend
thank you take care guys that's Adam or
Smith NFL Players Association president